Transcriber: Ece Gedik
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Herkese merhaba.
Öncelikle, bu nazik davetleri için
tüm Işık ailesine teşekkür ederek
cümlelerime başlamak istiyorum.
Bugün sizlerle kendi matematik yolculuğumu
paylaşmak istiyorum esasında.
Tabii, kendimi çok kısaca tanıtarak
başlamakta fayda olacaktır.
İsmim Uğur Mert, matematik öğretmeniyim.
Halen İstanbul’da SEV Amerikan Koleji’nde
matematik öğretmenliği yapmaya
devam ediyorum.
Lise kademelerinde derse giriyorum.
Bu yolculuk 1994 yılında başladı,
matematik öğretmenliği yolculuğu.
Ama bunun öncesinde ilkokul
hatta ortaokul yıllarıma baktığımda
esasında hayalim,
uzun yol otobüs şoförü olmaktı.
Fakat liseye başladığımda, teknik lisede
makine ressamlığı okudum.
Tabii makine ressamlığı okurken
yani hayalim hep uzun yol otobüs şoförü
ama çok gerçekçi gibi gözükmüyordu.
En azından şöyle bir bakış açısı vardı,
yani “Hayalin o mu?” gibi bir
bakış açısı vardı.
Evet, hayalim oydu.
Fakat işte liseye geçerken ortaokul
sonunda bir sınavlara giriyorduk.
Meslek lisesi sınavına girdik.
Meslek lisesini kazandım.
Sultanahmet Teknik Lisesi Makine
Ressamlığı bölümünde okudum.
Makine ressamlığı yapma hayaliyle
üç sene geçerken
okulumuz dört sene olmasına rağmen
üçüncü senede üniversite sınavına girdim.
O zaman öyle bir hakkımız vardı,
bir sene önce sınava girebiliyorduk.
Kazanırsak bir sonraki senenin
fark derslerini vererek
üniversiteye gidebiliyorduk.
Üçüncü sınıfta bütün tercihlerimi
matematik yaparak üniversite sınavına
girdim ve Matematik Bölümü'nü kazandım.
Matematik Öğretmenliği Bölümü'nü kazandım.
Şimdi tam bir hayaller hayatlar
durumu karşıma çıkıyordu.
İşte, hayalimde hep bir şey var ama, işte
makine ressamlığı, oradan matematik...
Ondan sonra bir sene erken
kazandığımda dedim ki,
“Ya ben bu bölüme gideyim,
en azından hani şey yaparım.”
Bilgisayar programcılığı, bilgisayar
da bir taraftan hoşuma gidiyor.
Yani daha o zamanlar çok bilgisayar
yok ama işte o programcılık falan
yeni yeni böyle parlamaya başlıyor.
Bir taraftan
çok revaçta bir meslek gibi gözüküyor.
Tamam dedim, hani matematik
bu yolu açar bana.
Hani bilgisayar programcılığı yolunda
o isteğime, o hayalime
bu yoldan erişebilirim.
Matematik bölümünde okuyayım ben, dedim ve
üçüncü sınıfta teknik liseden ayrılarak
Matematik bölümüne, Matematik Öğretmenliği
bölümüne başladım. Dediğim gibi,
burada da hayalimiz esasında
Matematik bölümünü bitirip
oradan bilgisayar programcılığı
yolunda ilerlemek.
Fakat yine planlar tutmadı.
Bu şekilde gerçekleşmedi.
Üniversite bitti.
Bu sefer üniversite bittikten sonra hani
erkek bir öğretmen adayı olarak
önümüzde askerlik vardı.
Şimdi,
şöyle bir plan yaptım kafamda.
Dedim ki şimdi okul bitti.
Hemen, işte bir bilgisayara
falan atılmayayım.
Askere gidene kadar bir taraftan
öğretmenlik yapayım, askere gidip
döndükten sonra esas bir
programcılık yolunda ilerlerim.
Öğretmenliğe başladım.
Ve işte o hep söylenen şey oldu.
Öğretmenliğe bir kere bulaştığınız zaman
bir daha bırakamıyorsunuz, bırakamadım.
94′ten bugüne kadar halen matematik
öğretmenliği yapmaya devam ediyorum.
Peki bu süreçte matematikle aram nasıldı?
Matematikle aram esasında çok iyiydi.
Ama bu çok...
Hani akademik başarıma yansıyor muydu?
Kimi zaman yansıyordu,
kimi zaman yansımıyordu.
Hani matematikten çok iyi
notlar da alıyordum.
Bazen düşük notlar da alıyordum.
Hatta şöyle bir örnek vereyim,
Matematik Öğretmenliği okudum ama
unutmuyorum 10. sınıfta
bir denemeye girdiğimde,
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam ya bir iki
matematik netim vardı
ya da matematik netim
hesaplanamıyordu bile.
O puanımın hesaplanması için dört
tane net yapmak gerekiyordu.
Matematik puanım hesaplanmamıştı özetle.
Yani orada bir şeylerin yanlış
gittiğini şöyle anladım:
Esasında benim çalışma sistemimde şöyle
eksik kalan bir nokta oluyordu:
Her şeyi öğrenmeye çalışıyordum.
Nedenini sorguluyordum.
Bu çok hoşuma gidiyordu.
Hatta şöyle, kendi kendime sorular
yazmaya çalışıyordum.
Şöyle bir fikir edinmiştim:
Hani derler ya, daha doğrusu demezler de
öğrenci olarak şunu düşünürsünüz ya,
“Ya acaba sınavda hangi soru çıkar,
onu sorar mı öğretmen? Bunu sorar mı?”
Ben o zamanlarda şunu düşünüyordum:
“Ya öğretmenler bu soruları
acaba nasıl hazırlıyor?”
“Eğer öğretmenin nasıl soru hazırladığını
birazcık anlayabilirsem, sınavda da
sorulan soruyu çözmem o kadar rahat olur.”
diye bir düşünce vardı aklımda.
Ve bunun için devamlı hangi konuyu
işlersek onunla ilgili
sorular yazmaya çalışıyordum.
2 3 soruyu birleştiriyordum, uzattıkça
uzatmaya çalışıyordum.
Kendi çapımda daha zor soru,
işte onun da zorunu nasıl yazabilirim
diye uğraşıyordum.
Ve güzel de oluyordu.
Şöyle güzel oluyordu, keyif alıyordum.
Ama bir taraftan da, işte devamlı
test sınavlarına giriyorduk.
Hani, sonuçta şuna bakıyorduk işte,
“A’yı mı işaretleyeceksin, B’yi mi,
C’yi mi, D’yi mi, E’yi mi?”
Tabii şimdi belki dinleyen
arkadaşlarımızın birçoğu
ortaokul öğrencisi.
İşte, ABCD var.
Liseye geçince ABCDE oluyor.
Şıkların sayısı bir tane artıyor.
Şimdi üniversite sınavına girerken de işte
bu beşinden birini işaretlemek gerekiyor.
Benim çalışma stilim, esasında buradaki
test sorularını çözmeye çok yetmiyordu.
Şöyle yetmiyordu, o test sınavlarını
başarabilmem için
birazcık fazla pratik yapmam gerekiyordu.
Biraz değil bayağı bir fazla pratik
yapmam gerekiyordu.
Yani çok soru çözmem gerekiyordu.
Ama temeli şuydu:
Konuyu iyi öğrenmem gerekiyordu.
Üstüne bol bol pratik yapmam gerekiyordu.
Konuyu iyi öğrendiğimi kendi
çapımda fark ediyordum.
Yani iyi öğrendiğimi düşünüyordum.
En azından eksiklerimi öğretmenlerime
çok rahatlıkla sorabiliyordum.
Onlar da çok sağ olsunlar, bıkmadan
usanmadan anlatıyorlardı.
Peki, bütün bu yaşadığım tecrübelerden
size aktarabileceklerim neler olabilir?
Onları da şu birkaç noktayla
ifade edebilirim.
Öncelikle bir kere,
soru sorun. Kendi
kendinize sorular sorun.
Öğretmenlerinize sorular sorun.
Ve en küçük detayları bile neden olduğunu
öğrenerek ilerlemeye çalışın.
Şimdi, şöyle bir şey söyleriz biz:
Matematik esasında bu küçük
detaylarda gizli.
Şöyle bir örnek vereyim size:
Mesela bir 1/3 sayısı. 1/3 sayısı
sayı doğrusunda nerededir?
Şimdi birçoğunuz bu sorunun
cevabını şöyle verecektir,
muhtemelen böyle de öğrendiniz.
Yanlış da öğrenmediniz.
Sayı doğrusunda 1/3,
0′la 1′in arasındadır.
0′la 1 arasını 3 eşit parçaya böleriz,
ve 0′a yakın olan birinci parçayı
aldığımızda oradaki nokta,
sayı doğrusu üzerinde 1/3′ün
yerini verir bize.
Peki,
sayı doğrusunda 0′la 1 arasını
3 parçaya nasıl böleceğiz?
Şimdi 1′i 3′e bölsem işte 0,33333 gidecek,
ondalıklı sayı, devirli ondalıklı sayı.
Peki ben bunu neyi kullanarak,
nasıl 3′e böleceğim?
Şimdi bunun cevabını bulmaya çalışın.
Şu anda hani Google gibi veya diğer arama
motorları gibi, yani internet gibi
bir dünya var önümüzde.
Buradan bunun cevabını çok
rahatlıkla öğrenebiliriz,
ulaşabiliriz.
Ulaşamadığımız noktalarda
öğretmenlerimizden yardım isteyebiliriz.
Onlarla birlikte tartışabiliriz.
Size ilk olarak ve en önemli verebileceğim
önerilerden bir tanesi bu olacaktır.
Muhakkak soru sorun, kendi kendinize,
öğretmenlerinize, arkadaşlarınıza ve
hoşunuza giden konularda birbirinizle
muhakkak tartışın.
İkinci önemli nokta, şimdi
öğretmenleriniz her konuda
o konuyla ilgili
bazı tanımlar yazdırırlar, teoremler
yazdırırlar, kurallar yazdırırlar,
özellikler yazdırırlar.
Soruları çözerken
işlem adımlarını,
“O soru tipi böyle çözülür,
bu soru tipi böyle çözülür.”
diye yapmaktan ziyade,
soruyu çözerken özellikle
konuların başlarında veya
konuları yeni öğrenirken
her öğrendiğiniz tanımı,
kuralı, teoremi, özelliği kullanarak
ilerlemeye çalışın.
Adım atlamayın.
Mesela bir adımı yaparken “Ha ben
şuradaki tanıma göre
bu soruda bu adımı gerçekleştiriyorum.
Şu özelliği kullandığım için bu adımdan
bu adıma atlayabiliyorum.”
Bu şekilde çözerseniz,
ve çok çok önemli bir nokta,
yazarak çözerseniz
öğrendiğiniz şeyler çok daha
kalıcı olacaktır ve gerçekten
öğrendiğinizi hissedip
işin keyfini alacaksınızdır.
Ha başlarda bu belki birazcık size
soruları yavaş çözüyormuş
hissiyatı kazandırsa da,
yani bu şekilde yapmaya başladığınızda
sorularda ilerledikçe göreceksiniz ki,
o adımları artık yavaş yavaş
çok fazla düşünmeyeceksiniz çünkü
çok düşündünüz zaten.
Artık orada hangi tanımı, hangi teoremi,
hangi kuralı, hangi özelliği
kullandığınızı çok iyi biliyorsunuz ve
bunları birçok defa tekrar ettiğiniz için
bunların hepsi de aklınızda
daha kalıcı olacaktır.
Evet, ikinci nokta buydu.
Ama buradaki en önemli nokta
dediğim gibi yazma konusu.
Muhakkak yazarak çalışın.
Yazmak önemli.
Yazmak size ne kazandırır?
Yazmak bir kere ne kadar anlayıp
anlamadığınızı ölçersiniz.
Çünkü anlamadığınız şeyi yazamazsınız.
Yazamadığınız yerde bir yerlerden
onu bulma ihtiyacı hissedersiniz.
Bu bir yerler nereler?
Gerekirse internet olur, Youtube olur,
öğretmenleriniz olur, arkadaşlarınız olur,
aileniz olur,
veya o konuyla ilgili tanıdıklarınız olur.
Evet, gelelim en önemli noktalardan
bir tanesine daha.
Bu öğrenme yolculuğu, esasında
öğretmenlerinizin, ailenizin, sizin ve
arkadaşlarınızın hep beraber
yola çıktığı bir yolculuk.
Fakat, kendi öğrenmenizin
sorumluluğunu lütfen kendiniz alın.
Çünkü öğrenmek keyifli bir yolculuktur,
ve bu yolculuğun kendi
açınızdan sahibi sizsiniz.
Tabii sınavlara gireceksiniz
Bunlar önemli.
Aldığınız notlar, bunlar da önemli.
Ama bunların en üstünde sizin
merakınız ve aldığınız keyif.
Eğer merak ederseniz, araştırırsanız,
neden olduğunu keşfetmeye çalışırsanız
bu size bir keyif katacaktır.
O keyif, öğrenmenizi zenginleştirecektir.
Ve son olarak şunu
sizle paylaşmak isterim.
Birçok defa şu soru bizim
karşımıza çıkar.
Belki siz de öğretmenlerinize
sormuşsunuzdur.
İşte matematik hayatın kendisidir.
Matematik her yerdedir.
Matematik her şeyin içindedir.
Ama bir de şunu sorun.
Mesela herhangi bir şeye baktığınızda
enteresan bir şey, ilgi alanınız olur,
hobileriniz olur
şunu düşünmeye çalışın:
“Acaba matematik bunun neresinde?”
Size şöyle bir örnek vereyim.
Mesela çok meşhur Pisagor’u
hepiniz duymuşsunuzdur.
Pisagor diyince şu an birçoğunuzun aklına
özellikle sekizinci sınıftan arkadaşlar
dinliyorsa hemen aklınıza
Pisagor teoremi gelir.
İşte hipotenüsün karesi dik kenarların
karelerinin toplamıdır.
Pisagor.
Ama esasında Pisagor’un çok da fazla
bilmediğimiz bir yönü daha var esasında.
Bugün kullandığımız, çaldığımız müzik
aletlerinin, müziğin, notaların
babasıdır Pisagor. İşte bugün öğrendiğimiz
Do Re Mi Fa Sol La Si Do.
Babası Pisagor’dur.
Ve nasıl keşfetmiştir biliyor musunuz?
Yolda yürürken
yaşadığı çağda demirci ustalarının
demirlere vurma sesini dinliyor.
Bakıyor ki bu seslerin bazıları
birbirine çok benziyor.
Bazen öyle bir uyum içinde geliyor ki, çok
hoş bir melodi gibi geliyor kulağına.
Ama bazen de çok rahatsız edici bir
gürültü şeklinde kulağına geliyor.
Diyor ki: “Ya acaba neden bu sesler
kulağıma bu şekilde geliyor?”
Ve oradan, işte o demir çubuklarını
ikiye bölerek
üzerlerine vurup çıkan sesleri
dinliyor. Üçe bölerek
çıkan sesleri dinliyor.
Bazıları birbiriyle uyumlu,
bazıları birbiriyle uyumlu değil.
İşte bunlardan, o 8 tane nota çıkıyor
bu yolculuktan.
Bu şekilde ilginiz olan şeylerin
nedenlerini bulmaya çalışırsanız,
şunu da göreceksiniz ki,
okullarda öğrendiğiniz o matematik,
esasında günlük hayatta
birçok problemi çözmenize
yardımcı oluyor.
Ve burada tabii tüm bunların
başlangıç noktası da meraktan geçiyor.
Bir şeyi merak ederseniz
öğrenmeye çalışıyorsunuz.
Öğrendikçe o konuyla ilgili
derinleşmeye başlıyorsunuz.
Evet, bu kısa süre içinde size hızlı bir
şekilde kendi matematik yolculuğumu
ve yaşadığım tecrübelerden ortaya çıkarak
birkaç küçük tavsiyede bulunmaya çalıştım.
Dinlediğiniz için hepinize çok
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Sağ olun.